what are your thoughts on Elon Musk he's
done a lot of cancelable things but he
doesn't get canceled like smoking weed
on Joe Rogan yeah stuff like that do you
think that was a mistake who knows cuz
it made a lot of people fall in love
with him where some people were like
dude that's so crazy he the CEO doesn't
even care you know he has guts he's like
you know what whoever is on board with
this is going to be on board with this
and whoever is not great cyanara and I
think that that's a cool mindset to have
if you're speaking to all people you're
speaking to nobody so he speaks to his
person and you're either a fan or you're
not I guess